Hey, everyone.
We're going to be taking a look at incentive pay and ...
compensation schemes.
Now, something we want to keep in ...
mind here is that every hour that we work comes with a choice.
Is the next sale going to be worth it?
Should we push ourselves a little bit harder or should we ...
take our foot off the gas?
This is marginal thinking here.
We're comparing the extra effort it takes to the extra ...
reward that we'll earn.
That's why we don't want to lock ourselves in a one pay structure.
Instead, we want to pick a plan that ...
fits our own effort curve.
So we're going to be earning based on how far we want to go.
Now, this is also important for the ...
company because companies want to align their interests in ...
the employee, so they're going to be looking ...
at how to correctly use incentive pay when they're ...
offering these structures.
Now, we know every employee is different.
That's why we let them take their own pay plan based on ...
how much effort they're willing to put in.
Each plan changes the way the marginal revenue stacks ...
up against our marginal cost.
We have three different ones here,
each earning different levels of base pay or commission.
We can see that there's low effort being taking place with ...
the first person and higher effort with the last person.
What we want to do is actually look through some ...
different incentive pay schemes and see how they work out.
So let's go ahead and jump into our base pay,
commission, effort,
risk, and where the marginal ...
replicas marginal cost for each of these pay plans.
So plan number one, base pay is $2,500.
Commission is 5% per sale.
And this is going to give us low effort and low risk.
Now, when we look at how ...
marginal revenue, marginal cost stack up the ...
person earning this particular plan,
what we find is that low commission means each sale ...
adds just a bit of revenue.
Marginal revenue grows slowly.
That means the marginal cost,
the effort it takes to make these sales catches up pretty fast.
This plan works pretty good for the people who plan to stop early.
Let's move on to our second plan here.
In our second plan, we have $0 in base pay.
Commission is 25% per sale.
And this rewards us, or this rewards the person ...
with high effort and high output.
Now, how does this relate to the ...
marginal revenue, marginal cost for that employee?
Well, since they're getting a big ...
payout for every sale, the marginal revenue they ...
earn is high from the start.
That means even as your effort increases,
it's still worth it because marginal revenue stays way ...
ahead of marginal cost for much longer.
This plan rewards high volume hustle.
So so far we have a low volume,
high and high volume hustle.
Let's look at our third plan.
Plan three plan this is more of a tiered approach here.
Our first sales get us 5% of the commission.
Next 10 sales get us 10% of the commission and then ...
beyond 15 sales we get 20% of the commission.
How does this relate to decisions at the margin?
Well, this plan is built for momentum.
Marginal revenue increases with every tier for this employee.
So the more they sell the more each unit is worth.
It motivates them to keep going even when effort starts to rise.
Now what we see is each plan changes how your effort pays off.
You choose based on how far you're willing to go and what ...
makes sense at the margin.
And companies can use this type of information to help ...
align their interests with the employees and that's all we ...
have. Hope you've enjoyed it.